ちょうどこの135というのは本当に使い
やすい道具だと思いますまあ1つの壁と
いうかま乗り越える課題と考えてもいいの
かもしれないよね青木サの人生系哲学
100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですねよく135の壁っていう風
に言われるともですけれども
アチーブメントがどんな風に突破してきた
のかっていうことについてお聞かせ
いただけますでしょううん
[音楽]
そうねまこれも1つのま解釈っって言えば
解釈なんだよね本当はだからそんな壁が
本当はないんだと思うんだよただあの昔
からその135というのを区切りとして
それを前向きに使いながら規模の拡大だと
か何かその目指していく時ににその手順
方法内容それを逆算してどういう風にして
いったらいいのかっていうことでえ考える
1つの道具としてきたという風に考えて
いいと思うしま世の中の人はそういう風に
使ってるとは思うんですけれどもまず社員
で言うとやはり10名30名50名さらに
は100名300名500名という風にま
1つのこう区切りとして社員数もある
でしょうしえ売上もあると思うんですよね
1億3億5億で
10億
30億そして今うちは50億の壁を超えた
わけですよねで今100億に向かってる
わけですよねで100億の壁を超えたら
300億500億という風に向かってくと
思うんです
よまあ1つの壁というかま乗り越える課題
と考えてもいいのかもしれないよねある
意味でまこれ今度は利益もそうだと思うん
ですよ1億の壁1億3億5億
10億30億50億という風にま利益の額
とかねま135
とま採用もやっぱり1名3名5名10名
30名50名
確かにうちは今30名の壁は破ったけど
やっぱ50名の壁ってあるよね
マネージメントにおいても10人自分の
部下を持ってるぱ30人の部下を持ってる
50人の部下を持っ
てるまちょうどこの135というのは本当
に使いやすい道具だと思いますそういう
意味ではねでアチーブメント自体がま創業
した時は社員5名資本金500万です
スタートしたわけですけれどもま10名の
壁っていうものはあったのかって言われ
たらそれは全く意識してませんでした10
名まではで次にじゃあ30名これ30名に
なるのにやっぱり時間かかったよねでなん
でかかったかって言うと1つはま当時ねえ
1990年に横綱千富の引退記念の
プログラムを作ったんですよこれがま売れ
なくて大変苦労することになりますだから
会社自体が経済的に非常に問題を抱えてる
時というのは採用にはなかなか向えないん
ですよで30人の壁にぶち当たってたん
だろうなで新卒採用を始めた2000え4
年からスタートして2005年に16人
採用したわけですけれどもその時に一気に
30人の壁は破ったわけでねそれで毎年
毎年新卒採用をして安定的に計画的にえ
人員の採用ができてその採用と育成に比例
して売上を伸びていきましたよねまそして
頂点の道口座という商品からまセール
スキルアッププログラムとか
プロフェッショナルセールスマネージャー
だとかボスウンのマネージメント
プログラムだとか結局自分のそういう
キャリアの中から身につけてきたものを
商品化してその映像プログラムの中に入っ
ているマインドノウハウスキルを抽出して
その企業の中に落とし込みをしていくで
その会社の売上の増大業績の向上に貢献
するためのコンサルタントそして
ファシリテーターを育てで最初は僕が
トレーナーでやってたんだけれもま採用し
た人間を育てていってファシリテーター
からトレーナーに育てていってということ
をやりながら毎年毎年新卒採用をして2桁
採用をずっと努力していってまあ20年間
で4億円以上の投資を深層採用にしてる
わけですよ220名の組織になってま
18億の経常利益になっているとまその間
もちろん中途採用の人間も入ってきてだ
けれども結局この壁っていうのは採用の壁
ってあったね採用の壁がもしなければ売上
ってもっと早く上がってますだけど逆に
言うとその安易に基準を下げなかった安易
に人数に焦点を当てるんではなく
て企業理念が上質の追求だからあくまでも
人材の質にこだわっので利益の方は
ちゃんと計画通り行ってるんですよただ
売上と満パワーがその通りになってない
ただ利益はその通りになってるってことは
小人数でも能力の高い人が育てて
るってことなんだろうねだから結果的に僕
はもし量に焦点を当ててたとしたら売上
返上の考え方を僕が持っていて顧客満足
中心の考え方を持ってなかったとしたら量
は成し遂げて社員人数は成し遂げてる
けれど利益はすごい少ない会社になってる
と思うわそれで企業文化そのものも今の
ような文化じゃないと思いますま良かった
んじゃないかと思うよねだから135の壁
をそうやって乗り越えながらま10名30
名50名の壁乗り越えて100名の壁
乗り越えて今3名の壁に社員ではね向かっ
てますよね今200従業員は255名かま
300人もうすぐだね来年300人の壁
超えるよねあの従業員ではま面白いよね
プロスピーカーが今600人だけど
やっぱりプロスピーカーも100人の壁が
あり300人の壁があり500人の壁が
あったよね会員も今JPSAの会員
4600人今年中に5000人超えると
思うんだけどやっぱり1の壁ってあったよ
ねだから周りからはそれなりの規模って見
られるけど僕規模意識したこともないしね
売上もあんまり意識してないんですよ正直
言ってただ少なくとも100億の壁は
破ろうよねっていうだ次の台の経営者
300億やろうとしてるから今未来創造宿
でねま十分でもそれはお客様に対しての
伴奏型支援でどんどんお客様の夢を叶える
成し遂げるためにこんな協力してほしい
あんな協力してほしいこんなサービスを
提供してもらえませんかって言われた時に
分かりましたとじゃあお手させてください
ていう中でどんどん事業が拡張しているに
過ぎないわけですよまそんなことかなよし
でしょうかねはい答えになってるかな
大丈夫
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
はい孫心だろうなあ目先の尊徳追わないっ
てことだよなんかすごくなんかがこのこと
言うとこの人気が狂ってんじゃないかって
思われるのかもしれないんだよね商売って
尊徳じゃないかって違うんだってこれは
絶対違うんだ
よお客様を味方にしなさいって僕は言っ
てるわけ
よ満足したお客様が最大の協力者になって
くださるんだよって絶対期待裏切っちゃ
だめだよって以上って感じかなえ是非
コメント欄にコメントよろしくお願いし
ますあとチャンネル登録もお忘れなく
よろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ます同じだもんね社員を裏切らないよ
俺だからやっぱり絆ものすごい強い組織力
が生まれてくるしだから毎年右肩上がりに
なっていって当たり前なんだよねだって
採用して育成できるわけだからで社会のが
圧倒的なマーケットがあるわけじゃないで
これ社会にとって必要とされない仕事をし
てたらこれはまた論外なんですよでも
世の中が今求めてくれてるもん本当に
間違ったマネジメントがもう世の中をメジ
じゃんもう制覇してるじゃん外的
コントロールが批判する責める文句を言う
ガガを脅すバ当る目先の帯出釣るこれ
スタンダードでしょ
これ
が今見直される時代が来たんですよ成長
する支援する励ます信頼する需要する尊重
する意見の違いて常にね交渉する事実私は
これを自分の家内に対しても子供に対して
もね社員に対してもこれを使って僕は豊か
な人生になってるので何が豊かってお金の
問題じゃないのよね多くの人はなんか資産
がねすごいねと鉄鉱上からね成り上がって
ねなんだかんだですごいじゃんとねでも
そうじゃないんだわ私の本当の豊かさは心
です俺めっちゃ楽な経営者だ
もんだって25年金の苦労してないんだよ
なぜ社員が働き者だからなんだってなんで
社員は働きなん
だろう自己実現の舞台だからでしょ仕事が
強制感がないから
でしょやらねばならないじゃないもん
みんな自分の課題として自分が登る山登り
をしてるわけ
じゃんね上司はそれを支援すんだもん
[音楽]
うんなんだろう僕だからもしかしたら
エベレストの山を登ってるのは社員で俺
もしかしたらほらなんだあの荷物持つ人
いるじゃんね一緒になって登る人あれなん
つゅうの知ってるシェルパシェルパ俺
シェルパかもしんないよひょっとしたら
うんでもシェルパーって番山登ってんじゃ
ないの
あれ1番重い荷物持って1番山登ってんの
シェルパだよねそこに喜びを見出せるのが
者だと思う
よいや結局やっぱり社員の質だろうなと
いうのは体じゃないんですよ頭なんですよ
結局ね頭で無からUを生み出せる人間を
取れるかどうかだと思うよ経営は作業型
人材っていくらでも採用できるんですよで
も価値を想像する価値想像型人材を増やさ
ない
とだからそれこそキエンスっていう会社も
ねある意味では社員数よりも社員1人
あたりの付加価値額付加価値生産性って
いうのすごく言うじゃないぱ1番大事なの
は最小の人員で最大の付加価値を
生み出せるかどうかだと思うのでまそう
いう意味ではアチーブメント自体の系は
間違ってはなかったのかなとは思うんだ
けどもそれ根幹が何かって言ったら数字を
追ってないってことだろうな
これ非常にユニークなことだと思う何追っ
てるのっやっぱりクオリティ質なんだよね
クンティカじゃなくてゼブラやっぱりこう
100年企業200年
企業継続できる
会社まそれを目指してるというよりも全部
そんなものは果実なんだよね根幹は何
かって言うとやっぱり考え方だと思う思
ますいやこれ本当受行性のフォローのため
に俺言ってんのよ一般の人を対象に僕は
YouTube始めたんじゃないんで受行
性が3日間の時間とねまテクノロジー
コースも14万円のお金を払って来てくれ
たま最受行料はもうね廉価だから誰でも
継続できる金額なんだけど僕の経営者講座
だってそうじゃないまずやっぱり3日間人
の縁で22万5000円というね対価を
払って参加してくれ
た絶対俺は裏切りたくないと思ってる
からなんだろうだから効率を系じゃないん
だよね効果性なんだよねもし効率追って
たら3日間の研修なんかやらないよ2日に
しちゃうよ時間も朝から晩までやらないよ
もっと短くしちゃうよあと通いやすくする
よそうじゃないんだわやっぱり集中して
本気でそこで熱くね議論かわしながら
ディスカッションしてどうしたら良い系が
できるのかをだ本気の人間だけ集めたい
から3日間でいいんですよ本気じゃない
やつ来ねえもんいいんだよそれで
ぶっちゃけたことなんだろうだから
うん僕ってやっぱり昔からちょっと変わっ
てたと思う
わいや本当ににそう思う今考えるとだ
セールスマン自体からそうだもんねだって
俺誰よりも紹介もらえたんだ
もんなんでかって言う
と
多分僕のこと嫌いじゃなかったんだと思う
んだよお客さんが分かりやすく言えばで
メンバーもめっちゃみんな頑張って
タイトルも取ってくれたし働きもになって
くれたし今でもそれは女だよね会社の文化
として
はでそれはなぜかと言うと例えばねタイト
ルって言うとみんなマネメダルで自分の
成績って考えるんだけど僕の場合は貢献
人数って考える
じゃんどれだけお客様に貢献できたか
が実績だっていう考え方だその数字じゃ
ないんだよねだから狩猟型の発想じゃない
んだよね
市場蓄積拡大型濃厚型の考え方なんだよね
だこれが
やっぱりまあ13号の壁とは言うけれども
楽に13号の壁を乗り越えてる理由だと
思う楽に馬なりでうん